uh and i really wanted to talk to you
james specifically because i know you've
got deleted a whole bunch of places i
try to share your video on twitter today
yeah and it said you're spreading
disinformation i'm like wait what i
clicked on the link and it gave me some
rambling jumbling nonsense that didn't
even address the claims you were making
right but but you couldn't like it you
couldn't comment right you couldn't do
anything about it so how has it been
using alternatives how have your numbers
uh have your numbers dwindled have your
numbers got higher how's the fight with
online censorship because they're going
after you pretty hard well uh and eric's
in the room with me i mean we've gotten
the most watched views ever
and i'm i'm we've trended on twitter
think of think of this think of it
i've trended on twitter and veritas has
shown on twitter for each and every
story we've broke and i'm banned from
twitter and i'm suing twitter
you can't make that [ __ ] up um the
reason why is because of distribution by
proxy so it doesn't matter like if i get
banned and he gets banned then the third
guy will upload the video and i i text
message a click to tweet link like i i
sent to you
and and you can click on it and it'll
embed the video populate now they'll try
to censor it and do things but um for
the most part they haven't taken me down
i have actually sent a letter to mark
zuckerberg this week saying please do
ban me i want you to ban me
um cut my tongue out of my mouth on the
eve of the release of the whistleblower
and it'll only make people want to tune
in to see what they have to say so i'm
leaning into the censorship i'm willing
to lose everything and i think you have
to be but every video that we've done
eric is in the room he's he's the guy
who who does social media with veritas
every video we've done has gotten
millions of views on youtube
and on twitter over the last few
releases
so um i'm hopeful as long as the content
is strong enough and true now i'm not
opining on the vaccine i'm not even
going to tell you my opinion about it
i'm just showing facts
and because i've sued the new york times
and sued twitter and sued cnn there's a
part of me that feels these companies
are actually afraid of me
by violating their own rules by by
crossing some rubicon they haven't yet
crossed so so far yes they'll add the
little tags and advertisements under the
video
but they haven't taken us down yeah i
remember it was very difficult to share
your video and i was just wondering you
know what's going to happen from here
but seeing all the alternatives seeing a
lot of different platforms jump up
seeing all the individual people kind of
rise up seeing the 75 000 dislikes on
the dr fauci documentary seeing the
chants everywhere i mean how can you not
have hope and and when the reality gets
so skewed on the mainstream media by the
government by the by the corporations
where literally joe biden was claiming
that the unvaccinated are the ones
putting the economy at risk today that
was literally what he was saying
something interesting happened to me uh
a lot of people were posting that when
they tried to put the link up to the
story they were getting warnings on
facebook have you seen that yes i've
seen i wish i had these messages in
front of me i've seen all types of weird
in fact eric one of the it seems like
they were actually manufacturing custom
messages just for me
it's like
so nice and it used to be able to ratio
people on twitter right so right so we
have you know six hundred thousand
people on telegram so if i just post the
url of the guy on twitter like making
some boneheaded comment ticket ratio
twitter disabled people from doing that
now you can't ratio people so they're
customizing the interface so that you
you're not allowed they're trying to
hide it did you know that uh there's a
website tracking likes and dislikes on
joe biden's videos showing that they
erase dislikes
but here's what i was going to say so
whenever i hear that there's censorship
on facebook i immediately i'm like all
right try me and i don't know i've had
no problem posting the the stories on
facebook they've not been deleted enough
again
no warnings facebook is oh really here
here's one russell brandon blue check
mark
project veritas is taking the exciting
leap from mostly harmless [ __ ] to
[ __ ] that will actively cause people
to die
so so i i sent this url to 500 thousand
people but if you go to his twitter page
you can't comment on him unless russell
brandon is mentioned so they're taking
steps to eliminate this but um again it
wasn't my claim i'm quoting pfizer
executives
you understand the distinction like i'm
not opining about what i think about
about the virus or emails in writing i'm
quoting their vice president saying we
must lie to the people we must deceive
the people this is this is a
the law of non-contradiction you
shouldn't lie to people whether you're
left right republican democrat it
doesn't you shouldn't lie
i was actually just talking to sean
spicer on newsmax about uh they edited
joe biden's comments because he made the
snide comment where like you know when
cinema gets harassed doesn't happen to
people with secret service
and uh and and so he's saying nbc
reports this comment but they cut out
that part so you don't get the full
context it's deceptively edited my
immediate reaction was like oh i love it
they deceptively edit their videos and
then they can write all day about how
james o'keefe is doing that when he's
showing you people literally say things
in a conversation oh i have one quick
story luke about something you said
about censorship so one of the things
they do which i know you're familiar
with is they use these fact checkers you
know like fact check or experts say
story has been debunked i love that one
experts say it's like imagine if you're
someone who walks on in on you cheating
on your wife you say i'm sorry honey
experts say this has been debunked
but anyways the the usa today
uh what they do is they're they work
with facebook to do a fact check right
so they can put out a piece
that's used to justify to get your thing
banned on facebook so facebook can say
well experts say usa today so yesterday
called me tim after the first
video the the hhs was to blow on our
series two weeks ago and i said oh here
we go again
usa today is setting this up so i don't
know what to do because no matter what i
say doesn't matter they've already
written their article they're just
asking me for comment
so what i did is i called usa today and
i recorded myself
leaving a voicemail for usa today and
then i distributed my comment to usa
today to everyone
preempting them saying if you don't
publish my comment i will sue you
usa today did not put out the article
whoa and then facebook didn't take the
article down so i think the way to
preempt communists the way to because
we're dealing with this let's call it
what it is communism the way to preempt
communists
is to publicly announce what they're
going to do record yourself giving the
comment ever hear world i'm i'm giving
my comment to usa here is my comment if
you don't publish this i'm going to sue
you and they know i'm not bluffing
so so usa today didn't publish that
article and facebook didn't take us down
it's it's what we mentioned before about
um you know in a previous segment we
were talking about uh congress
questioning someone from you know pfizer
about fetal tissues the fact checkers do
the same game they someone will make an
assertion and then the fact checkers
will take a similar but different claim
to make it sound like they're debunking
the claim so next thing you know we're
going to see snope saying are fetal you
know the claim a project veritas story
releases a bombshell people are now
saying yes yes non-psychological
non-sequitur it's it's a it's not
it's not so much that they're lying it's
that they're it's the logical
non-sequitur it's the fallacious logic
they change the subject and then and
then there's this game of telephone and
before you know it o'keefe made a claim
that i did not make that claim that's
brilliant that's the funniest thing
about i think almost all of the work you
do is when you put these videos out
you're not saying i believe in this
policy and that policy and i voted for
bush like none of those things happen
right they'll they'll make the they'll
it's a straw man argument effectively is
what it is can you can you guys just see
wikipedia already
uh we're working on it uh we're gonna
sue the users on wikipedia and since i
last saw you as you know we defeated the
new york times motion to dismiss the new
york times
appealed that tried to issue an
emergency stay so we couldn't depose
them we defeated their emergency stay so
we're we're getting pretty far in our
lawsuit obviously the wheels of justice
turn slowly
but um i think it has deterred them tim
from from lying how you you launched
that thing recently the the defense fund
i think uh yes project veritas legal
organization which is under our 51c3 it
was your idea actually the people's
defamation defense fund we just named it
project veritas legal nice so you stole
my id and renamed it
well technically it wasn't my idea but
don't worry about that
yeah
either way it's it's amazing that that's
happening we need more of that and i
would say what you're doing is is not
even controversial it's just journalism
it's what journalism used to be a lot of
journalism of what we see right now is
literally regurgitating what the power
structure says
and then saying now do this you don't
even tell people what to do uh i mean
you have your own personal opinions you
you have your own biases everyone has
their own biases but there's a big
distinction between what we're seeing in
the mainstream media and what we're
seeing with alternative media what we're
seeing with you and i think we need more
of that more than ever um and then i'm
just trying to think of other ways maybe
we could help facilitate that or get
involved i think journalism is is
reluctant to get into an exposed
position where they're seeing as
affecting events
and rather than just reporting to them
and traditionally there was always this
adversarial nature to journalism but
these days like you say they only print
the established line they only are
allowed to publish what they're told on
the record in fact
quote unquote journalists wait to see
what the corporation has to say and only
when they've given give been given
permission
to to report the thing do they report
the thing it's become so much worse even
in the last couple years they don't
publish anything that's not the
established public lines cnn's health
advisor just came out today and said los
angeles has just invoked some of the
strictest vaccine policies in the united
states excellent this needs to spread
everywhere that's not journalism that's
that's
hiring a lunatic yes sociopathic crazy
person that wants to enforce their will
onto you journalism is about letting
people hear the story letting them know
decide themselves letting them see the
evidence and then just leaving it there
for the viewer to decide what is right
for them informed consent something that
again needs to come back more than ever
and and i i would say we don't have any
of it i don't think i think these people
are so fundamentally unaligned even on
the first amendment these days and and
there's this great uh uh reporter named
david shaw who wrote i'm a great
believer in the reporter as an observer
firsthand observation is the old
ultimate documentation almost every big
story that we do
we often have to impersonate someone in
order to have the firsthand observation
of the thing happening that's what
investigative journalism does
you use whistleblowers you go undercover
et cetera et cetera so this is the
perversion the perversion i've seen is
that they won't say
anything unless the corporation or
government official tells them you're
allowed to say this thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you